[Music]
okay so I have the honor today being
joined by my favorite showrunner with
three names Lauren Schmidt historic
Lauren how are you today I'm great thank
you so much this was an interview I
really wanted to do because to me you're
like a type of like rock star showrunner
where I feel like a lot of the
showrunners kind of like hide in a cave
somewhere you don't really hear from
them you don't see them but you see a
lot of you which i think is awesome
because you show passion for a very
passionate fan base for a show like The
Witcher and people want to see that and
I think that's so important so you're
not new to doing writing for you know
things with big fan bases already so I
was wondering what is that like knowing
that you're jumping and adapting things
that already have a huge fan base that
expects so much and now your showrunner
for something like that and you'd
previously written on daredevil and
defenders and even umbrella Academy so
I'm just wondering what kind of pressure
that was and what goes into your head
like thinking about that you know I
never try to think about it as pressure
I just think about it in terms of
excitement I mean really the worst thing
the worst feeling in the world as a
writer is to work on something that no
one is ever going to watch um a lot of
us go through that in pilot season every
single year which is writing something
that will never ever get made and it's
hard on the soul after a while so to
have the exact opposite experience which
is to write something that has this
enormous passionate fan base that we you
know we were hoping would show up and
watch watch you know The Witcher and
hopefully like it um it's it's really
really exciting because you know you're
writing something for people who are
hungry for more material who want more
material now of course what that brings
with it is knowing that you're not going
to please all of those people and it's
been a really interesting two weeks
since the show came out because
obviously it's doing it's doing very
well for Netflix around the world which
is super exciting and
would be easy just to start listening to
the accolades and what I've been trying
to do is seek out the parts of the
fandom that aren't as happy and to
listen to what they were expecting to
see and what they think could be better
in season to you it's been a really it's
been a really interesting thing to dig
into and to sort of get all of the
feedback and all of the again all the
accolades and all of the criticism and
sort of start sifting through it
see I really respect you saying that
because it really also just kind of
lends to what you actually tweeted about
a couple days ago which I'm actually
gonna quote directly where you said I've
been thinking about echo chambers let's
be honest it's human nature to seek out
the like-minded to surround ourselves
with those who see the world in the same
way there's nothing wrong with that you
know what is wrong limb Bassanio's who
aren't in your chamber I say this as a
person who his whole heart has been
poured into this project for two years
no one should be degenerate for having
an emotional and passionate response to
The Witcher negative or positive be kind
to each other and be respectful so
that's really awesome to me as someone
who also reviews things and I think
that's such a cool thing to hear from a
showrunner that you're able to even like
listen to both sides of the argument and
preach to people to be respectful of
each other and not be so personal you
know and that's really cool of you now
when you're actually going on Twitter or
Instagram and you see like The Witcher
trending and people constantly talking
about it everywhere are you looking at
everything or is there like a healthy
amount where you're like I I need a
break from this there is definitely a
healthy amount you know what's really
handy is to have family around me that
is like stop looking at your phone and
come back to us what was brilliant about
it coming out on December 20th is
because I obviously was able able to
monitor a lot I was getting some
feedback from Netflix about how well it
was doing and and the explosion of
excitement on social media tons even me
and there's been a lot of a lot of stuff
on social media over the last two years
but no you have to stop taking it in
after a while because also you find
yourself sometimes becoming so minut
about details and I will end up arguing
with a really passionate fan about one
tiny thing and you're like okay wait
let's step back and let's take a broader
view and what I try to do with those
conversations is sort of take the
he takes a 30,000 foot view that's a
phrase that we use in writing all the
time which is like if you're just
looking at the broad swipes from above
from 30,000 feet you know what are they
and that allows me to say you know what
people really like together this season
they really thought that seeing her
backstory was cool that's been the
majority of the response not every
response but it's the majority you know
what other people felt though is that
they didn't get to know Siri enough okay
great so I can take that piece of
information and start making you sure
that season 2 we actually get to delve
into that character a little bit more to
spend time arguing with a single person
is never actually going to be helpful
it's really just trying to look at the
big to big broad you know these yeah and
I think to add to the positives you were
just saying which I agree with
everything you just said but I think the
biggest positive for me and a lot of
people would agree with this is that
Henry Cavill was the perfect casting
choice for garel I think you guys nailed
it with that and I thought he was
amazing and I think that was the most
important thing to get right and I think
having gotten that right is such a big
success on its own and just adding to it
like you said it's got a lot of praise
too and how Netflix released this most
popular TV shows at 2019 and which or
was second which is just incredible with
Netflix being such a big juggernaut that
you accomplished that so props to you
Lauren and I was wondering so you're
getting you know so much success now you
see how a show like okay everyone's
gonna compare it to Game of Thrones
right and it's like kind of like that
thing everyone's trying to find their
fix of fantasy and this was something
people were kind of looking for that as
a thing was that kind of something you
guys were aware of and conscious of when
you were making the show like was Game
of Thrones talked about a lot um you
know something we were super aware of
that that frankly a lot of fans a lot of
press were making those connections it's
not something that we thought about on a
daily basis on set during writing or in
post but we knew that those comparisons
were there be made especially because
when we started writing Tim Jones hadn't
even premiered teammate yet they
actually didn't they hadn't even
premiered it I think they were starting
to roll it out right as was kind of
shooting so we had no idea what that
reaction to it was gonna be I think only
once it came out that people started
looking at the vacuum that it left and
how to fill it and then suddenly it was
look we've got this this caromed show
The Witcher the truth is you know and
obviously I think people now are finally
beginning to realize this the thing that
a mature Owenton Witcher have in common
is that they're both fantasy shows and
the both fantasy shows that we hope
we'll find a big broad audience after
that they're not alike at all and this
is I think then the really interesting
thing I mean tonally they couldn't be
more different The Witcher is is I would
say more more magical it has more
monsters and magic and a lot more humor
if you come into it expecting a big
earnest sweeping drama that's not what
you're going to get so I do think that
now that it's out that distinction
actually won't be made as often because
people actually know now they have both
pieces of material to compare
yeah and that thing to were like you
want to have it separate on its own and
that's what was so good about which or
two is it is so great on its own with
that like putting out of your head the
comparisons and now as an actual
business side of it Lauren you see like
basically the zeitgeist is that you know
Game of Thrones objectively didn't stick
the landing that great do you toss and
turn at night thinking wow this is a
huge project I'm sure running in The
Witcher has a huge fan base what if I
mess up the end like do you guys have
like a long game plan with this do you
like do those thoughts come to your head
I mean you know of course they come to
your head because you know we all are
constantly and the writer you are in
your brain so often anyway and you know
you're always thinking about oh god what
if I mess something up the truth is
though our plan is pretty solid and not
that that means that we know everything
we're going to do over the next you know
two or three or seven or twenty years
what I mean is we have the books I don't
feel the need to go beyond the existing
books they are great source material
Anderson caustically has written all of
them there is a natural ending to them
and I feel like as long as we stick that
landing which is the ending of the books
and then we'll be good okay that's
really good to hear and also I noticed
that you have such a great diverse and
female heavy writing team was that
something you went into conscience of
trying to make that happen or just kind
of happen on its own
of the makeup of the writers room and
it's interesting I love that you use the
word diverse because it's one of those
words that it's obviously such a
hot-button word because people always
assume it means skin color and what I
like to talk about is the diversity of
the writers room in terms of many many
factors so yes we have a fairly equal
split of men and women in our show we
also have people who are older people in
their fifties people in their 20s you
know we make sure that we have different
sort of life experiences you know we
also make sure that we have people who
were born in the United States people
who were born in Europe people who were
born in Eastern Europe we want to make
sure that we have different families and
this is goes to sort of sexuality of
course but also you know people who
still live close to their their family
of origin or people who were adopted it
really is about diverse experiences
because what you asked any writers room
to do is to bring their own life to the
story to bring their own emotional
context to the story that's how it is
how it is ever going to resonate with an
audience so you need to make sure that
if we're asking people to have context
and to have emotional resonance that
their experiences are different or else
the show is going to be really OneNote
and really blab so yeah it is very
purposeful you know but it's purposeful
on a lot of factors not just the color
of someone's skin so running on that too
with your writers room just to wrap this
all up I had asked us to is now that
your showrunner here and you had so much
writing experience just way back even
going to West Wing which is another
great written show do you as a
showrunner you wrote for Witcher Episode
one in the finale as well which are
great but do you sit there and also like
are you hands-on with all the other
episodes you are you kind of showrunner
who's with the writers every day in that
writers room or do you kind of check in
and out no I love to be with them every
single day
it was interesting season two it was a
little bit more difficult because we
were still shooting season one so I was
actually splitting my time between being
in production and being in the writers
room but for season one I was there
every day here's the important thing
though is that I believes that that
writers should write I don't expect them
to all try to sound like me and I
certainly for godsake I do not want to
rewrite all of their words or
that is not going to severe time or my
time so what I really do is empower
writers to write their own episodes I
will often do a polish on them at the
end if anything you've shifted a lot of
times that polish is about continuity
between episodes as opposed to making
individual changes within the episode
itself but I really want the episodes to
represent the writer who wrote them and
I think that's part of what makes season
one so special is that you can kind of
get a sense of the writer behind the
show so if you watch episode 3 for
instance which was written by beau
DeMaio beau has spent a lot of time
writing a lot of monsters and horror and
that's the thing that really rises to
the surface in that episode what I loved
about episode 6 which he shouldn't my
writer and hand-carry Hall it eats a lot
more of a sort of romantic adventure
which is right up Hailey's alley so
allowing the writers to to really own
their scripts and own their episodes
they've become the episodes become that
much more rich because they have the
tone of the writer himself
yeah that's beautifully said and Lauren
just to wrap things up I have to ask
this it would be a sin but is there
anything you can give us to expect for
season 2 you know what Steve it is I can
give you some generals to expect okay
which is you know our our characters
will all start interacting a lot more
you know season one test for the most
part Jennifer Gallup and Siri very
separate in season 2 you will start to
bring them all together this is really
going to be the foundation of the three
of them as a family it's not always
going to go well you know they're not
going to be a really happy family from
the beginning they have a lot to learn
about each other they're strangers and
they have to start learning what they
mean to each other how they can help
each other and when to leave the others
alone I think it's going to be fun
because it really is getting into this
dynamic of a family of choice you know
the family that you choose to be with
and that's that's those the stories I'm
most excited to start telling that is
awesome I cannot wait it's just amazing
how fun and exciting it is to watch what
your season one and the last thing
Lauren I was just gonna ask I saw that
you had this fundraiser on your
Instagram that you did during the
holiday season
where you raised like it seems like
$50,000 to help I guess kids get gifts
and stuff teen progress can you just
tell us a little bit more about that and
what exactly went on there sure so this
is something that we've been doing for
nine years
my oldest son Harry was born five weeks
early and ended up in the pediatric
intensive care unit or the NICU and
truly whoo-hoo life was safe and he's a
happy healthy nine-year-old boy today
and so the very first Christmas after he
was born we started talking about what
we could do to give back to the hospital
in the very first year myself my husband
and my best friend Michelle went and
bought a bunch of toys and delivered
them done to the hospital just for any
kids who happened to be there over the
holidays and some of my friends saw what
we were doing and said oh hey tonight
you know can I give you ten bucks and
have them buy something for me too or
I'll write you a $50 check I'd love to
pitch in and so in the second year we
decided to formalize it a little bit
more and we've started you know
basically an online fundraising campaign
and to date we've raised I believe it's
almost three hundred thousand dollars at
this point for kids and of course we
raised so much money and bought so many
toys over the years that we now have
extended to five other organizations in
Burbank California where this hospital
is to make sure that we're taking joy
not just to the hospital but to other
kids in the area who need it and the
best part of it honestly in fact it's
all grassroots it is literally myself
and Michelle and Mike sending out emails
to our friends saying hey if you want to
join if you want to donate money if you
want to come shop we do all of the
shopping ourselves if you want to load
or unload toys from vans or put them in
the hospital we'll take any any help we
can get and it truly has become the best
the best part of our year it's amazing
how big it's grown that's amazing that's
something just be applauded that makes
you just even cooler than you already
are Lauren thank you so much for joining
me today I really appreciate it is there
anything else you wanted to plug before
you head out nope I think I think we
covered it all yeah I hope so and if if
you have if you listen you listen for
some reason you haven't watched The
Witcher watch it and not only watch The
Witcher you can go on Netflix
you can have a Lauren Schmidt historic
binge and watch her episodes of
daredevil umbrella Academy she wrote so
much the defenders it's all great stuff
Lauren thank you so much again for
joining me and I hope to talk to you
again soon thank you so much for having
me it was really fun